اكتمل المربع الذهبي لكاس العالم بعد
الدراما كرويه هائله في الدور ربع النهائي
من البطوله ومفاجاه لطاحه بالبرازيل
وانجاز مغربي الى قبل النهائي اليكم بعض
الاحصائيات والارقام
ميسي يعادل مواطنه باتيستوتا اكثر لاعب
سجل الارجنتين بتاريخ المونديال برصيد 10
اهداف البرازيل تخرج من دور ربع النهائي
للمره الرابعه خلال اخر خمس مشاركات
بتاريخ كاس العالم كرواتيا اول منتخب
بتاريخ كاس العالم يصل المربع الذهبي وهو
يملك فوز واحده فقط كرواتيا تتاهل بركلات
الترجيح في دوري 16 والربع النهائي
للمونديال الثاني على التوالي فرنسا تفوز
على انجاز لاول مره في كاس العالم بعد
الخساره في نسخه 1982 و 1966
اول ركله جزاء لانجلترا بتاريخ كاس العالم
شباك فرنسا تتلقى اهدافا في جميع
مبارياتها بهذا المونديال خمسه لقاءات
تحديدا لاول مره منذ عام 1950